we're in Edinburgh and I don't if you  can see it but this huge rig here has  been set up ready for referendum night  for all the different media to work here  and it still appears to be a very very  close vote polls seem to put no just  ahead but only just keep meeting loads  of people who are suggesting that they  were staunch no supporters and now  they're going to vote yes because  they've simply been convinced and they  think that the No campaign  scaremongering has put them off as the  David Cameron coming up today they say  they find it a little bit cringe-worthy  that said no I've got a lot of support  from businesses this week suggesting  that if people vote yes it could be  dangerous for the economy